we're going to try and do an experiment
today it's called the gallium beating
heart so it's a real quite a cool
experiment you take some molten gallium
and then you submerge it or you put it
underneath a layer of soft uric acid the
sulfuric acid reacts with the gallium to
form gallium sulfate and it changes the
surface tension so it all pulls up into
a ball and then relaxes and there's this
really nice neat oscillating reaction
where you get sulfate on the surface or
no software on the surface so you see
big changes in surface tension and the
the piece of gallium is seen to beat
like a heart so we thought we'd try that
today with a little bit of gallium which
I'm trying to melt in my hand right now
many years ago a professor bet me a
hundred pounds when 100 pounds was a lot
of money that the melting point of
gallium was lower than that of caesium
and I said it was the other way around
I wasn't current courageous enough to
take up the BET ORN and be rich just a
small nugget of gallium and you can see
if I tap it on the hot plate it's real
metal so now we're going to try and melt
it hopefully in my hand in my first
video about gallium I said that it
wasn't a very interesting element with
not much at many applications and we've
had emails from people who are outraged
there's one email from a gentleman in
America whose company makes tons of
gallium salts that have quite important
applications and of course gallium is
particularly important in new generation
of compounds so-called semiconductors
that are used in the electronics
industry so if I stand and hold it for
long enough in theory the temperature
should come from my hand the heat she
comes from my hand so it should melt the
gallium and then eventually we should
have a small amount of liquid so gallium
you can form an amalgam with this
material with all sorts of other
materials like indium and tin and in
fact indium tin and gallium is used as
the material inside many many
thermometers which he
used in the medical industry because
it's not as toxic as mercury which was
traditionally used you may have heard of
Mendeleev he was the guy that sort of
conceived or brought together the
periodic table and at the time that he
did this in about 1870 gallium hadn't
been discovered so he predicted it its
chemical and physical properties and he
called it eco aluminium approximately
five years after that it was fine using
a spectroscope so now we see it's melted
it looks just like a little ball of
mercury rolling around on my hand you
can see the thick skin to just develop
the surface tension causing it to form
such a beautiful bulb we're going to
take our molten gallium and we're going
to put it underneath a layer of dilute
sulfuric acid about the same strength as
battery acid so now we're going to make
the acid and to do that we're going to
dilute concentrated sulfuric acid with
water now it's always important to
remember that when you dilute acid you
always put acid into water because the
reaction can be exothermic and we want
to dissipate the heat in the water so
that it doesn't squirt up on our faces
the water was room-temperature but if I
hold the measuring cylinder here is
actually very hot it's nearly 40 50 60
degrees C so now before we do our
experiment we've got to allow it to cool
we do that by simply by running cold
water outside the tube so this is the
gallium that we melted on our hand now
let's see what happens when we add the
sulfuric acid Wow
did you see that I did what happened so
the shape of the ball or the lump of
gallium has changed because we've
changed its surface properties we've
made gallium sulfate on the surface the
surface tension has got higher and it's
pulled up into a nice ball okay so
that's the first step of the beating
heart what we've seen is the gallium
which was relaxed flat on the surface
has pulled up really quite quite sharply
and that's the first stage whether the
in beat of the heart now we've got to
make the heart relaxed so what we're
going to do is we're going to use
dichromate die creates a fantastic
oxidant and we're going to put a small
amount of it in and see what
happens so galium I realize now is named
after France it was discovered by a
Frenchman and his name comes from the
old name for France school
you
so what we're doing in this experiment
is we're changing the surface tension
the gallium so these are the forces that
hold the liquid into either a ball or
allow it to wet and flatten on the
surface so when the gallium is naked
okay it's it's actually quite flat and
it wets the surface but when we put it
under sulfuric acid we form gallium
sulfate on the surface this increases
the surface tension and then pulls the
gallium so it's in a nice probe ball
what we then do is we dribble a small
amount of dichromate solution in which
removes the sulfate from the surface and
allows the gallium to go flat if we add
the required amount of dichromate to the
amount of acid then we can get the ball
to flatten and come back up flatten and
come back up so it looks like a beating
heart at the moment we're really quite
excited at Nottingham because steve
little my periodic videos colleague has
made a new compound in which he has got
an atom of uranium to bond to an atom of
gallium and this is exciting because
this is the first time that chemists
have ever seen a bond between these two
atoms the sort of Terra Cotta in color
it's really a deep orange and brown so
it's a bit like quick discussion of
course they're not naked uranium and
naked gallium but each of them have
other things bonded to them but it's the
first time that anybody has seen a
gallium uranium bond it was one of those
great moments you know being a chemist
it's like being on a roller coaster you
have some days where you just wonder why
am I doing this and then you have
fantastic days where
because it's to be the first to be the
first person who's ever made this
particular filling the gap whatever it
is but it's a real thrill when you are
the first person to make a compound
doesn't exist out in the galaxy in space
it's never existed on our planet before
but now we've made it for the first time
that's a really good thing to do we're
really very excited a new union has been
formed within the periodic table and
it's been done here at Nottingham